question now who is crossing our
southern border good question too
shocking numbers from the southwest so
far this year agents have reported
encountering 50 people who are listed on
the terror watch list
bill malugion is live in hidalgo texas
with details on that bill what you find
out
bill good morning to you these are brand
new numbers from cbp and they are pretty
eye-opening they show that under
president biden the number of people on
the terror watch list arrested by border
patrol has shot up significantly
compared to president trump let's get
right into those numbers if we can pull
this graphic up this is for our southern
border brand new cbp number showing
arrests on the terrorist screening
database so far for fiscal year 2022
which still has four months left there
have been 50 of these arrests by border
patrol on the tsdb you take a look at
the years prior to that that's up big
over fiscal year 2021 which was 15
fiscal year 23 fiscal year 19-0 then six
then two you get the picture there take
a look at the trend these last couple of
years the number of these tsdb arrests
have exploded there have been 65 already
these last couple years the previous
four years combined before that there
were only 11. case in point people
always trying to sneak into this country
if we can pull this video up we embed it
with texas dps this is a group of
runners trying to hop a fence and get
away from law enforcement
did not work out for them though this
group of runners later arrested by state
troopers and border patrol off a nearby
highway we pull up the second piece of
video here we also embedded with these
texas dps troopers in the middle of the
night you'll see there were migrant
runners just hiding in the brush all
over the place they shine their lights
they start popping out of the brush
numerous runners they're arrested as
well and then this last piece of video
we'd like to show you a pursuit
involving texas state troopers with a
human smuggler one of their troopers
gets behind a guy smuggling at least 10
illegal immigrants and then you'll see
there is a bailout the driver bails out
and all of the illegal immigrants start
bailing out of the vehicle they start
running all over the place the trooper
is outnumbered he decides to go after
the driver and texas dps tells me he was
successful in taking that driver down
and arresting him for human smuggling
and back out here live guys highlighting
those terror watch list numbers it's
extra concerning considering the fact
that multiple cbp sources tell me just
since october there have been more than
440 000 known godaways here at our
southern border you do the math on that
that average is out to about 1 800
people slipping past our agents every
day the question is who are those people
we'll send it back to you it's
unbelievable bill you think about how
much money we have spent for 20 years to
make sure that they do not pass through
our airports and get on our airplanes
and this could be happening arguably
every week
uh very interesting reporting there stay
on it i know you will thank you bill
mollusion hidalgo texas today that's a
great point dana